und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend Versprechen gegeben
Versprechen gebrochen zum zweiten Mal
hintereinander 400.000 neue Wohnungen
sollte es jedes Jahr geben im
vergangenen Jahr waren es aber nur knapp
300.000 und auch in diesem Jahr soll die
Zahlen nicht ansatzweise erreicht werden
Schätzungen liegen bei 250.000 zudem
bricht die Zahl der Baugenehmigungen ein
und die der Stornierungen von
Bauvorhaben steigt also was läuft da
schief klar die steigenden Bauzinsen und
die Materialkosten die sind nicht
hilfreich hilfreich scheint aber auch
nicht die Politik zu sein zum baugipfel
Morgen zudem die zuständige Ministerin
und der Kanzler geladen haben werden
deshalb wichtige Akteure fehlen Britta
Spickermann
Jörg Brömer ist Bauunternehmer im
hessischen Wiesbaden einer wenn nicht
der Größte von der Industriehalle bis
zum Einfamilienhaus die Firma baut alles
Brümmer merkt die Krise weniger
Baugenehmigungen weniger Bauaufträge
oben drauf ausufernde Bürokratie nein
Lippenbekenntnisse von der Regierung die
braucht er nicht wir reden momentan von
cosmetischen Maßnahmen vielleicht noch
eine Verbesserung der Abschreibung
vielleicht noch eine kleine
Wohnbauförderung aber keine Maßnahmen
die den Wohnungsbau wieder zur alten
Stärke zurückführen würden Römer ist
sauer auf die Regierung und nicht nur er
gleich zwei große Verbände kommen morgen
nicht zum Treffen ins Kanzleramt sie
vermuten eine reine Show Veranstaltung
und die könne sich keiner leisten der
Verband Haus und Grund etwas nicht dabei
die Regierung hat in der Tat die Zeichen
der Zeit nicht erkannt der Wohnungsmarkt
aber auch der Finanzmarkt haben sich
derart stark bewegt dass der normale
Traum vom Eigenheim nicht mehr erfüllt
werden kann und das führt dazu dass wir
mehr Mieterinnen und Mieter in
Deutschland haben und für die fehlt der
bezahlbare Wohnraum das ist die
Beschreibung eines Teufelskreises die
Mieten steigen weiter eine Trendwende
ist nicht in Sicht die bauministerin
verfehlt auch dieses Jahr ihr Ziel
400.000 neue Wohnungen zu bauen und zwar
deutlich der Druck auf sie mehr zu tun
wächst deshalb werden wir jetzt
konjunkturelle Impulse setzen zusammen
mit den Beiträgen der Länder stehen da
etwa 45 Milliarden Euro bis 2027 zu
Verfügung doch allein das Geld ist es
nicht Vorschriften müssen abgespeckt
Genehmigungen beschleunigt und
Energiestandards lockerer gehandhabt
werden das wurde die Branche schon lange
die Ministerin signalisiert
Entgegenkommen ihre Idee zur Sanierung
zuerst öffentliche Gebäude Privathäuser
rückt Geiwitz in Zeiten der Wohnungsnot
vom gebäudeenergiegesetz ab der
spd-generalsekretär antwortet und weicht
aus es ist mir wichtig an dieser Stelle
zu sagen dass für die SPD klar ist dass
wir Dinge wie ein sanierungszwang oder
ähnliches was mancherorts diskutiert
wird definitiv nicht mittragen werden
ich glaube jetzt ist erstmal genug
reguliert in diesem Bereich und das klar
zu sagen die Liberalen wollen
Lockerungen die Grünen naturgemäß nicht
und die Union sieht für die Zukunft der
Baubranche schwarz nach den
Koalitionsvertrag ist es ja auch so die
energetischen Standard sollen noch
einmal jetzt verschärft werden was das
Bauen noch einmal um 10 % verteuern
würde das ist in dieser Situation
einfach nicht angemessen keine guten
Vorzeichen für das Treffen morgen
wichtige Akteure fehlen und welche Rolle
spielt der Klimaschutz und dann ist da
noch die Industriegewerkschaft Bau sie
fordert vom Kanzler den doppelwurms
diesmal für bezahlbares Wohnen
folgt heute nach Sonneberg das zweite
kommunale Spitzenamt für die AFD in
Thüringen also dem Bundesland in dem die
Partei unter Führung von Björn höcke als
erwiesen rechtsextrem eingestuft wird
und die Antwort lautet nein das ist
etwas überraschend denn im ersten
Wahlgang lag der afd-kandidat 18,4
Prozentpunkte vor dem parteilosen
Amtsinhaber aber die Bürger und
Bürgerinnen in Nordhausen haben sich in
der Stichwahl gegen den afd-mann und für
den alten Oberbürgermeister entschieden
mit
54,9%. dabei hatten CDU und FDP nicht
mal eine Wahlempfehlung abgegeben Gründe
und Hintergründe jetzt von Daniela
Sonntag
es ist ein Kuh und Kai Buchmann der alte
und neue Oberbürgermeister von
Nordhausen kann es wohl selbst kaum
fassen
[Applaus]
vielleicht war die ursprüngliche
Einschätzung dass der AFD sie sicher
waren eine falsche Einschätzung trotz
vorübergehender Suspendierung buchmanns
trotz laufenden Disziplinarverfahren
wegen Mobbing lieber ihn als die AFD
eine Initiative aus Vereinen
studentenkirchen und Parteien hatte
dafür mobilisiert wir haben gezeigt dass
es auch anders geht dass man auch gegen
die AFD ankommen kann wenn man die Leute
die Leute die Leute aktiviert das
Ergebnis für viele überraschend und
überraschend eindeutig Nordhausen am
Rand des Harzes eine international
ausgerichtete Hochschule und ein
schweres historisches Erbe mit dem
ehemaligen KZ Mittelbau Dora ein
afd-mann als Repräsentant dieser Stadt
eine deutliche Mehrheit hat sich nun vor
allem dagegen entschieden ich bin
begeistert hat dass die Demokratie sich
überweisen konnte denn es ist nicht nur
ein Ergebnis für Buchmann sondern auch
eins gegen Prophet gegen die AFD dabei
galt Jörg Prophet noch heute morgen als
Favorit lange lag der AFD Mann vorn
feierte schon am vergangenen Wochenende
vor dem Rathaus mit Blasmusik und Partei
Größen
wahlkampfhöhepunkt fast wie eine
Siegesfeier da war schon bekannt dass
ein Post von ihm im Thüringer
Verfassungsschutzbericht zitiert wurde
Geschichtsrevisionismus politisch
Absicht geht es umdeuten so die Analyse
jetzt die Wahlniederlage ich bin mit den
Aussichten reingegangen dass der
souveräne in Nordhausen eine
Entscheidung trifft und hätte mich
natürlich gefreut mehr Vertrauen
bekommen zu können aber der
anziehunghaber hat seinen Bonus gespielt
kein afd-mann an der Rathausspitze
Erleichterung beim Direktor der
Gedenkstättenstiftung Buchenwald und
Mittelbau Dora es wurde deutlich gemacht
dass Zivilgesellschaft wenn sie
zusammenhält wenn sie sich engagiert den
Vormarsch der rechten und der
rechtsextremen stoppen kann und das ist
ihr geschehen und deswegen ist das so
ein wundervoller Abend die AFD setzt in
Nordhausen kein neues Häkchen auf die
Liste der kommunalen Posten vorerst
endet der Siegeszug nächstes Jahr wird
in Thüringen weiter gewählt unter
anderem Landräte und Landtag
fragen wir noch mal nach bei Melanie
Haack unserer Studio Leiterin in
Thüringen Melanie schönen guten Abend es
ist ja ein überraschendes unerwartetes
Ergebnis gibt es dafür schon eine
richtige Erklärung
ja die richtige Erklärung wird sich auch
in den kommenden Tagen finden und vor
allem wenn man sieht was die anderen
Parteien aus diesem Ergebnis machen
werden also wir haben das hier erlebt
hier im Bürgerhaus hinter mir das schon
vor Ende der auszeitszählung die ja sehr
lange dauerte dass Ergebnis kam ja erst
kurz vor halb neun viele Menschen
hierher gekommen sind die hier vor
standen und gerufen haben und am Ende
war der Jubel sehr groß und man muss
sagen am Ende nach der ersten Wahl war
es natürlich die Frage für wen
entscheidet man sich jetzt die Stadt war
gespalten aber vor zwei Wochen hat sich
ein Bündnis gegründet ein Bündnis der
Zivilgesellschaft wie Sie es nennen mit
verschiedenen Vereinen Verbänden und
Kirchen die hier mobil gemacht haben auf
der Straße es gab gestern noch ein
Bürgerfest und aber auch in den sozialen
Netzwerken und was ich oft gehört habe
hier dass die Menschen gesagt haben wir
haben diskutiert und wir haben lange
nicht mehr so über das Thema diskutiert
wie ich wählen werde das heißt also
nicht nicht wegschauen sondern die
Menschen haben sich bewusst mit ihrer
Wahlentscheidung auseinandergesetzt sagt
Melanie Haack unsere Studioleiterin aus
Thüringen vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzung ja man muss ja in keine
Glaskugel gucken um zu wissen was los
gewesen wäre wenn der afd-kandidat
gewonnen hätte wie nach jedem Erfolg
dieser Partei hätte es Empörung und
Unverständnis darüber gegeben dass man
aus Sicht der Gegner eine
antidemokratische verfassungsfeindliche
und menschenfeindliche Partei wählt das
ist der falsche Weg das findet Sabine
rennefant sie ist Kolumnistin und
Autorin beobachtet die deutsche Politik
und Gesellschaft unter anderem aus ihrer
ostdeutschen Perspektive sie stammen aus
Brandenburg und damit einen schönen
guten Abend schönen guten Abend
sie sagen moralische abscheu- und große
Erregung um die Erfolge der afds
eigentlich nicht das richtige warum ist
das nicht der richtige Reflex ihrer
Meinung nach wir haben das ja jetzt in
den letzten zehn Jahren probiert und
auch wenn jetzt in Nordhausen ein Erfolg
gefeiert werden kann ist das
grundsätzlich jetzt noch keinen Moment
für uns glaube ich zum Aufatmen also es
hat ja nicht geklappt wir haben immer
wieder moralische Empörung gezeigt in
den letzten zehn Jahren trotzdem ist die
AFD immer stärker geworden und das
Problem ist einfach je stärker der ja
der moralische Abscheu ist diese
Dämonisierung auch der der AFD desto
größer ist glaube ich in Teilen der
Bevölkerung der Reiz sie dann erst recht
zu wählen weil dann hat man das Gefühl
okay ich bin dann wenigstens böse aber
nicht unwichtig oder schwach und werde
wohl möglich auch gehört aber heute hat
es ja funktioniert es wurde ein Bündnis
geschlossen und haben sie dafür
vielleicht schon eine Erklärung
erstmal muss ich sagen es zeigt ja auch
bei allen Diskussionen das ist wirklich
immer ganz wichtig zu gucken wenn wir
auch noch auf Ostdeutschland gucken also
70 Prozent der Menschen in
Ostdeutschland wählen nicht die AFD die
schweigende Mehrheit wählt nicht die AFD
und das hat sich in Nordhausen heute
auch gezeigt die schweigende Mehrheit
hat nicht geschwiegen sondern die haben
sich organisiert und ich glaube wir
können aus dem was in Nordhausen jetzt
passiert ist auch ganz genau angucken
was sie dort anders gemacht haben und
das ist sowieso etwas was mich auch in
der Medienberichterstattung oft auch
irritiert hat also dass man immer guckt
ja AFD und warum kriegen die das hin
warum guckt man nicht was machen
diejenigen anders die es geschafft haben
jetzt ist es ja so Wahnsinn ist uns ein
klein demokratischer Vorgang und die AFD
ist demokratisch gewählt die die sie
nicht wählen sagen ja aber sie ist
antidemokratisch und fürchten eine
Normalisierung der Partei sie nicht
ja Normalisierung also ich glaube wir
haben keine Normalisierung im Moment
weil es gibt ja bis auf einzelne Stimmen
eigentlich keiner keinen im politischen
Parteienspektrum der jetzt sagt wir
machen eine Koalition mit der AFD also
diejenigen das sagen das sind wirklich
versprengte Stimmen und was halt bisher
passiert ist das wenn man so ja man
bedient eigentlich das narrativ der AFD
in dem man so sagt alle Parteien stehen
gemeinsam gegen die AFD also das bedient
eigentlich genau das narrativ der der
AFD die sagt wir sind die Märtyrer und
ihr müsst uns wählen um euch gegen die
anderen durchzusetzen und das muss man
wirklich durchbrechen und man kann auch
nicht wenn da 20 bis 30 Prozent der
Leute AFD wählen wollen man kann die
auch nicht ähm ja hinter einem Mauer
sperren sozusagen diese Menschen aber da
vielleicht dann doch noch mal auch
nachgefragt also soll man bei einer
Partei die in Teilen rechtsextrem ist
insbesondere wenn wir nach Thüringen
schauen unter Björn höcke die Dinge dann
nicht mehr beim Namen nennen oder was
ist der Umkehrschluss umso mehr beim
Namen nennen also das würde ich mir
wünschen also die Partei hat bekämpfen
der hat angehen aber versuchen die
Menschen auch wieder zurückzuholen gute
Politik zu machen es kann ja nicht sein
also so viele Leute in den letzten
Jahren haben angefangen das politische
System zu hinterfragen Leute die keine
Nazis sind es bringt halt nichts zu
sagen die Leute sind abgeschrieben man
muss wirklich an die harte inhaltliche
Politik gehen und die Leute auch wieder
zurückgewinnen also wichtiger wichtig
ist ja auch der Punkt den sie vorhin
schon mal sagten 70% ungefähr wählen Sie
nicht und wir reden über 30 Prozent und
sie machen einen sehr wichtigen
Unterschied zwischen der Pei und Partei
und die denen die Sie wählen also wählen
die Menschen denn die AFD ihrer Meinung
und ihre Erfahrung nach sie kommen ja
aus Brandenburg aus Protest Provokation
veränderungs Müdigkeit oder doch genau
wegen der zum Teil völkischen
nationalistischen spaltenden Aussagen
ja da gibt es ja verschiedenste Studien
und Überlegungen ich würde sagen es ist
eine Mischung ich glaube ein großer Teil
wen sie wird sie wirklich aus Protest
weil sie das Gefühl haben sonst nicht
gehört zu werden es ist aber auch so
dass die AFD eine Zeit lang tatsächlich
als einzige Partei in
migrationskritische Position vertreten
hat und ich sage jetzt nicht dass ich
diese Position Teile oder dass sie
bisschen besonders sympathisch ist aber
wenn man gegen die Flüchtlingspolitik
von Angela Merkel war dann war eben die
AFD die einzige Partei die dagegen auch
gesprochen hat also ich fürchte es ist
schon so dass die AFD auch Themen
anspricht die in unserem Diskurs auf den
letzten Jahren zu kurz gekommen sind
corona-pandemie ist ein anderes Thema
ich glaube das hat einfach viele Leute
auch an dem System zweifeln lassen sagt
Sabine rennefans Kolumnistin und Autorin
vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung heute
Abend alles Gute sehr gerne wiedersehen
ja und sie hat gerade schon angesprochen
dass es manche Themen gibt die gefühlt
jedenfalls nicht angesprochen werden
aber im Moment vergeht jedenfalls kein
Tag an dem sich aktuell nicht irgendein
Politiker zur migrations- und
Asyldebatte äußert meist mit einer
Lösung anders heute der SPD-Chef und
damit beginnen Heinz deine Nachrichten
ja für SPD-Chef klingenball gibt es kein
Patentrezept gegen irreguläre Migration
er weigere sich so zu tun als gäbe es
die eine zaubermaßnahme sagte er der
Bild am Sonntag solche Maßnahmen liefert
nur populistische Schlagzeilen
stattdessen forderte der entbündel von
Aktionen um die Zuwanderung zu begrenzen
die EU hat den Angriff auf Polizisten im
Norden des Kosovo verurteilt bei dem ein
Polizist getötet und mehrere verletzt
wurden die Polizisten wollten eine
Straßenblockade nahe der Grenze zu
Serbien auflösen als sie mit schweren
Waffen angegriffen wurden bei dem
Feuergefecht sollen auch drei der
Angreifer getötet worden sein der Kosovo
beschuldigt Serbien hinter dem Angriff
zu stecken in den letzten Monaten hatte
es in der Region immer wieder gewaltsame
Auseinandersetzungen gegeben
kurz bevor das spanische Parlament in
der kommenden Woche über einen neuen
Regierungschef abstimmt haben heute in
Madrid mehrere 10.000 Menschen ihre
Unterstützung für Wahlsieger Alberto nun
die es felchow begründet ihm fehlt im
Parlament bislang eine Mehrheit verliert
er die Abstimmung könnte der bei der
Wahl Zweitplatzierte Amtsinhaber Sanchez
versuchen eine Regierung zu bilden
[Applaus]
Italien nimmt Abschied von seinem
ehemaligen Präsidenten Giorgio
Napolitano der vorgestern im Alter von
98 Jahren gestorben ist der frühere
Ministerpräsident und EZB-Chef Draghi
war ebenso unter dem Besuchern im Senat
wie Regierungschefin Meloni überraschen
wir auch Papst franziskus gekommen um
vor dem Sack zu beten der
Staatsbegräbnis für Napolitano der
zwischen 2006 und 2015 im Amt war findet
am Dienstag statt
und auch heute wollen wir nach bergkara
Bach schauen auf die Enklave die uns ja
die ganze Woche über schon beschäftigt
als Aserbaidschan am Dienstag mit einem
Militäreinsatz startete hatten ja viele
die Befürchtung die Krise mündet wie
schon zweimal zuvor in einem Krieg da
die armenischen Kämpfer aber dann tags
drauf ihre Waffen niederlegten wurde der
Militäreinsatz beendet als erfolgreich
verbucht sprich das autokratisch
regierte Aserbaidschan übernahm dort die
Kontrolle wer Karabach gehört
völkerrechtlich zu Aserbaidschan wird
aber mehrheitlich von Armenien bewohnt
und deren Schicksal wie Zukunft ist
total unklar Armenien verlangt die
Menschen mit einer UN-Mission zu
schützen denn die Angst vor ethnischen
Säuberungen ist sehr groß bei manchen
sogar so groß dass sie Bergkarabach
verlassen und Richtung Armenien ziehen
von dort berichtet Nina
sie sind wütend über die Fakten die in
diesen Tagen geschaffen wurden das
berkere Bach aufgegeben wurde dass er
mir nicht eingeschritten ist
schuldig so die Demonstrierenden ist
ihre Regierung
diese Regierung ist unfähig irgendetwas
zu tun sie verschenkt nur unser Land
selbstverständlich sind wir bereit die
Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen wenn es keine
andere Möglichkeit gibt aber es bedeutet
auch der Karabach aufzugeben das wollen
wir nicht es ist unsere Heimat
Bilder aus der Grenzregion die ersten
Flüchtlinge durftenberger wach verlassen
nachdem sie tagelang dort eingeschlossen
waren sie haben es nach Armenien
geschafft es sind Tränen der
Erleichterung auch wenn sie ihre Heimat
vermutlich für immer hinter sich
gelassen haben
wir haben drei Kriege erlebt drei Mal
sind wir geflohen und konnten immer
zurückkommen
diesmal wissen wir es nicht
die Unsicherheit ist groß auch bei denen
die sich schon an den russischen
Militärstützpunkt gerettet haben wer
kann uns Garantien geben wir hatten
einen Liter Benzin sind geflohen und
hierher gekommen wenn wir jetzt gehen
werden dann die jungen Leute die bleiben
umgebracht
ihre Toten müssen sie zurücklassen die
Gräber erst am Morgen ausgehoben etwa
200 Menschen sollen bei dem
aserbaidschanischen Angriff am Dienstag
getötet worden sein in bergkara Bach
fiel das an allem Lebensmittel Benzin
für die Flucht um ihre Handys zu laden
sind sie hier aufs rote Kreuz angewiesen
anders ist der Kontakt zu den Verwandten
in Armenien nicht möglich auch Susanna
Petrus jan hat seit Tagen auf diesen
Anruf gewartet ihre Mutter und
Geschwister gehören zu denen die
festsitzen morgen sollen sie ausreisen
dürfen falls die aserbaidschanische
Armee sie lässt
Düdingen
der letzten Tage war jede Verbindung
abgeschnitten die Dörfer waren von
Aserbaidschanern umstellt die Menschen
saßen fest vielleicht werden sie Ihnen
morgen einen Korridor geben um ihr Land
für immer zu verlassen
Armenien macht sich nun bereit bis zu
40.000 Flüchtlingsfamilien aufzunehmen
er erwarte einen Massen Exodus sagte
Regierungschef Pasching an die
Belastungsprobe für Armenien sie hat
gerade erst angefangen
die Ukraine kämpft an mehreren Fronten
und muss sich gleichzeitig auf das
vorbereiten was da kommt russische
Anschläge und Angriffe auf die
Energieversorgung so wie es auch im
letzten Jahr ja gern Winter geschehen
ist als sie deutsche Außenministerin vor
zwei Wochen in einem
elektrizitätsumspannwerk zu Besuch war
kündigte sie an dass man das Energienetz
mit der Ukraine engmaschiger
knüpfenwolle was die Ukraine zur Zeit
schon selbst tut um sich zu schützen
Alicia jung
[Musik]
so klingt es wenn die Menschen in der
Ukraine nicht wissen welche Schäden sie
am nächsten Morgen erwarten bei
Angriffen diese Woche wird zum ersten
Mal seit Monaten wieder die
Energieinfrastruktur zum Ziel und 300
Tonnen Hilfsgüter zerstört darunter fast
die gesamte Winterhilfe der Caritas im
Westen des Landes der dachten das
Leonberg ja in der Westukraine ist
wenigstens sicherer Ort auch alle
botschaftler sind immer in Lemberg
können etwas passiert aber leider jetzt
ist sie solche und gewisse Zeit dass es
gibt kein sicherer Platz in der Ukraine
fast nichts wird in den nächsten Monaten
so wertvoll sein wie diese Generatoren
diese Firma in Kiew war im vergangenen
Herbst und Winter leer gekauft die
letzten Monate haben sie versucht so
viele Generatoren aus dem Ausland zu
beschaffen wie möglich
jeder bereitet sich schon auf den Winter
vor und versucht auf Nummer sicher zu
gehen
es gibt bereits mehr Nachfrage nach
Reparaturen Wartung und Neukauf
diese großen Generatoren können ein
mehrstöckiges Gebäude versorgen sie
werden an Schulen und andere kommunale
Einrichtungen geliefert wer sich keinen
eigenen leisten kann wird es nach
Angriffen nur hier warm und hell haben
in einem der 700 Sammelpunkte von Kiew
die Luftabwehr der Hauptstadt auch mit
Hilfe aus dem Ausland fängt zwar viele
Raketen ab doch die bereits entstandenen
Schäden an der Infrastruktur sind groß
so ist wir konnten diese Schäden die gar
63% der Energieinfrastruktur betreffen
immer noch nicht vollständig reparieren
es sind wohl die letzten warmen Tage da
muss sich die Ukraine bereits fragen wie
sie die kälteren überstehen wird
zum Sport an diesem Sonntag zuerst zur
Fußball-Bundesliga bayer Leverkusen hat
viel zu eins gegen Heidenheim gewonnen
und steht jetzt in der Tabelle auf Platz
2 hinter dem punktgleichen Bayern die
eine bessere tourdifferenz haben im
zweiten Sonntagsspiel trennten sich
Eintracht Frankfurt und der SC Freiburg
Unentschieden 0:0
in der Formel 1 ein weiterer Sieg für
Max first dappen heute beim Großen Preis
von Japan sein Red Bull Team sicherte
sich damit vorzeitig den Titel in der
Konstrukteurs Weltmeisterschaft auf die
Plätze 32
beim Berlin-Marathon gab es heute gleich
mehrere besten Marken eine davon eine
Weltrekordzeit mit der die Äthiopien
über die Ziellinie lief
auch der Protest der klimaaktivisten
kurz vor dem Start konnte tigista nicht
aufhalten in einer fabelhaften Zeit von
2 Stunden 11 Minuten und 53 Sekunden
läuft die 29-Jährige Äthiopien
Weltrekord im Marathon eine Verbesserung
von mehr als zwei Minuten der vier Jahre
alten Bestmarke von Brigitte in Chicago
zum fünften Mal in Berlin gewinnt Elliot
kippschocker bei den Männern in zwei
Stunden zwei Minuten 42 Sekunden auch
das eine Bestmarke ideale Bedingungen
ermöglichen auch eine neue deutsche
Bestzeit am anal Petros und der Boot in
zwei Stunden vier Minuten und 58
Sekunden den von ihm aufgestellten
Rekord umfasst eineinhalb Minuten und
wird Neunter
wenn wir über Asteroiden reden dann
denken manche ja gleich an den
Katastrophenfilm Armageddon und erwarten
das aller aller schlimmste aber die
Gefahr dass uns eines dieser Geschosse
aus Staub und Geröll wirklich mal
treffen wird ist gering treffender ist
dann doch eher dass sie uns in der
Weltraumforschung weiterhelfen könnten
wie dieser hier genannt Benno erzählt zu
den größeren seiner Art und ist Teil
einer waghalsigen Mission die die NASA
vor sieben Jahren gestartet hat und zwar
mit der weltraumsonde Osiris Rex hier in
Originalgröße zu sehen vor drei Jahren
ist sie bereits auf dem Asteroiden
gelandet um eine Probe zu nehmen
ziemlich erfolgreich geschätzt 250 Gramm
Material konnten da gesammelt werden
danach flog die Sonne dann jahrelang
wieder Richtung Erde zurück und warf die
Kapsel inklusive Asteroiden Spuren ab
und jetzt werden forschende darin nach
Geheimnissen zu den Anfängen unseres
Sonnensystems suchen nachdem die
wertvolle Fracht heute am Abend auf der
Erde konkret in der Salzwüste im
Bundesstaat Utah gelandet ist Heikes
lanski und der Jubel der NASA
es ist der Moment auf den sie sieben
Jahre hing gearbeitet haben die Spannung
mit Händen zu greifen Jubel im
Kontrollzentrum der NASA bei der
Live-Übertragung alle Berechnungen alle
Vorhersagen alle Vorbereitungen geglückt
in der Wüste des Bundesstaates Jutta
segelt die wertvolle Fracht fast auf die
Minute genau zu Boden eine Kapsel
abgeworfen von einer Sonde einige
Stunden zuvor geschützt von einem
Hitzeschild rund
102000 km über der Erde gebremst und
stabilisiert von Fallschirmen Experten
der NASA sind kurz nach dem Aufprall am
Fundort nähern sich langsam dem Objekt
in dem sich ein wissenschaftlicher
Schatz befindet Staub und Geröll Proben
vom Asteroiden
das Material in der zurückgekommenen
Kapsel wird uns teilweise dabei helfen
die Lehrbücher über unser Verständnis
der Chemie im früheren Sonnensystem neu
zu schreiben
2016 begann die lange Reise ins All am
Weltraumbahnhof Cape Canaveral die Sonde
Osiris Rex brauchte allein zwei Jahre um
ihr Ziel zu erreichen den tief schwarzen
Asteroiden namens Benno
weitere zwei Jahre belauerten die
Wissenschaftler mit der Technik an Bord
die kleine felsige Gesteinsmasse bevor
vier Jahre nach dem Staat in einem
komplizierten Manöver eine geröllprobe
erfolgreich entnommen wurde für die NASA
das erste Mal
was Theorien sind die Überbleibsel der
Entstehung des Sonnensystems ein
makelloses Beispiel für
planetenbausteine ihre Untersuchung
hilft uns zu verstehen wie die Erde und
alle Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem
entstanden sind
rund eine Milliarde Dollar war der NASA
diese Außerirdische Beute Wert
schätzungsweise 250 g Geröll die größte
bisher eingesammelte Probe von einem
Asteroiden eine spektakuläre Mission ein
Stück sonnengeschichte und Aufschluss
über seltene Erden und Metalle im All
wenn die Fundgrube auf der Erde zur
Neige gehen sollte Anfang nächster Woche
soll der Behälter komplett geöffnet
werden und der kleine Inhalt
Wissenschaftlern in aller Welt zur
Verfügung gestellt werden
beeindruckend die Woche neigt sich dem
Ende entgegen die neue klopft aber mit
zahlreichen Ereignissen an hier ein
kleiner Überblick im Ausblick von Dara
Hassan Sade
[Musik]
am Montag in Peking wird der EU China
Dialog zu Wirtschaft und Handel beginnen
die EU wirft China vor mit Subventionen
die Preise für Elektroautos zu drücken
und den Markt zu verzerren besorgt ist
die EU auch über Chinas Einfluss auf
kritischer Infrastruktur in Europa ein
Dialog mit Streitpotenzial
am Donnerstag werden die EU
Innenminister in Brüssel über
Flüchtlingspolitik beraten die
Bekämpfung von Schleusern der Stadt
einer neuen Militärmission im Mittelmeer
und eine verstärkte Überwachung der EU
Außengrenzen stehen im Zentrum der
Verhandlungen
am Freitag werden die Rolling Stones
eine Single aus Kopplung in London
vorstellen ihr jüngstes Album soll in
Gänze im Oktober auf den Markt kommen
Fans dürfen sich auf neue Musik von
alten Musikern
noch kurz die Wetteraussichten morgen
scheint nach Auflösung einiger
Nebelfelder die Sonne im Nordwesten
durch dünne hohe Wolken an der Nordsee
weht der Wind frisch und böch die
Temperatur steigt auf 18 bis 24 Grad
sind doch schöne Aussichten gut dass wir
frei haben denn morgen übernehmen hier
Hanna Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
und um 0:30 Uhr gibt's dann die nächste
heute Express dann von uns und vom
gesamten Team vor und hinter der Kamera
einen guten Start in die neue Woche
machen sie es gut wo auch immer Sie sind
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]